kritische marke überschritten als erste
deutsche millionenstadt durchbricht
münchen eine wichtige corona baumgrenze
streit über härtere strafen für raser
der neue bußgeldkatalog bleibt außer
kraft im bundesrat gibt es keine
einigung und bundesliga start zum ersten
mal ohne fans meister bayern münchen
trifft im auftaktspiel der neuen saison
auf schalke 04
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg freitagabend willkommen
zum nachrichtenüberblick schön dass sie
dabei sind wie auch rudi cerne für den
sport hallo guten amt eigentlich wäre
morgen in münchen anstich fürs
oktoberfest das ist natürlich längst
abgesagt jetzt drohen den 1,5 millionen
münchnern womöglich drastischere
einschränkungen denn auch die bayerische
landeshauptstadt hat die kritische
corona grenze überschritten
abgesehen von cloppenburg in
niedersachsen liegen alle kreise mit
mehr als 50 neuinfektionen pro 100.000
einwohnern in bayern die städte würzburg
und kaufbeuren sowie die landkreise
kulmbach und garmisch partenkirchen und
jetzt also auch die landeshauptstadt
münchen
sibylle bassler berichtet die meldung
des örtlichen gesundheitsamtes trag die
münchner am nachmittag die kritische
marke an neuinfektionen erstmals
gerissen die stimmung verunsichert cola
gefahr auch einfach zu hoch ist viele
leute halten sich an keine anweisungen
also da müsste man meinem dafürhalten
nach mehr durchgreifen
auch im rathaus ist man von den hohen
infektionszahlen nicht wirklich
überrascht weil das was viele befürchtet
haben und was auch fast alle
prognostiziert haben nämlich dass nach
der urlaubszeit sich die fallzahlen die
zahl der infizierten wieder erhöhen wird
dass das eingetroffen ist weitere
risiken zu viel feiern zu viel alkohol
zu wenig distanz der leichtsinn steigt
und mit ihnen die gefahr sich
anzustecken münchen hatte versucht das
zu verhindern mit alkoholverbot distanz
gebot offenbar das nicht gereicht
großveranstaltungen wie das fußballspiel
am abend finden ohne publikum statt
als sie gefahr sie immer da wo viele
menschen auf engem raum zusammen sind
vor allem dann wenn man drinnen ist und
vielleicht noch wenig luft zirkulation
ist also geschlossene räume würzburg ist
der korona hotspot mit 70 neuinfektionen
pro 100000 einwohner innerhalb einer
woche
das infektionsgeschehen begünstigt durch
viele faktoren das späte ende der
sommerferien reise rückkehrer aus
risikogebieten aber auch die
umfangreichen tests im freistaat
über 600.000 tests allein der letzten
wochen davon sind 6000 positiv gewesen
das heißt die positive reiserückkehrer
und wer viel testet sieht auch viel und
ein ende der pandemie sei nicht in sicht
somit bleibt der einzige schutz abstand
hygiene und atemmaske wenn sie fragen an
die virologin haben die eben im bericht
zu sehen war kein problem sie können sie
stellen gleich in zdf heute live in der
zdf- heute- app und auf zdf heute.de um
19 uhr 30 geht's los
zur corona gesamtlage in deutschland da
haben sich im durchschnitt der
vergangenen sieben tage täglich 1560
menschen neu infiziert so die zahlen der
johns hopkins universität gestern lag
der wert noch bei 1 1490 weltweit haben
sich mittlerweile mehr als 30 millionen
menschen mit dem virus infiziert und in
immer mehr metropolen werden die
einschränkungen wieder verschärft mit
israel geht nun gleich ein ganzes land
in dem zweiten corona lockdown nach dem
ersten im frühjahr wird das öffentliche
leben nun erneut ausgebremst weil sich
die zahl der neuinfektionen dort
dramatisch entwickelt gestern waren es
fast 4800 fälle bei rund neun millionen
einwohnern für drei wochen gelten jetzt
wieder strenge kontakt regeln und das
zum israelischen neujahrsfest michael
bewerunge berichtet eigentlich ein ganz
normaler freitagnachmittag in einem
einkaufszentrum in tel aviv doch heute
schließen die geschäfte nicht für
schabbat und neujahrsfest sondern für
ganze drei wochen auch elisa bari widmet
sich den letzten kunden ihr kleines
nagelstudio ist der ganze stolz die
kleinunternehmerin ist besorgt als
selbstständige bekommt sie kein
arbeitslosengeld sondern nur einen
zuschuss für ihre ausfälle
wir wissen noch nicht wie viel wir vom
staat bekommen wir müssen weiter steuern
zahlen aber wann uns geholfen wird das
wissen wir nicht
manche kunden sind genervt schon wieder
eingesperrt zu sein
die israelis sind gesellig es fällt
ihnen schwer auf verabredungen zu
verzichten
ich feiere heute abend mit freunden in
therapie eigentlich wollte ich zu meiner
familie in jerusalem
aber ich habe angst dass ich auf dem
rückweg erwischt werde andere halten die
zwangspause für unvermeidbar der lock
down ist richtig unter der längst kommen
müssen dann wäre das land heute nicht in
diesem zustand jetzt kontrolliert und
sperrt die polizei die straßen die
meisten sind aber ohnehin leer obwohl
der bewegungsradius etwas größer als
beim letzten mal ist 1000 statt 100
meter auch einzelne aktivitäten am
strand sind diesmal erlaubt trotzdem
bietet sich an diesem wochenende ein
ungewohntes bild am meer
nur wenige trauen sich hier und sind
auch schnell wieder weg
die regierung weiß nicht was sie tut sie
macht etwas nur um irgendetwas zu machen
am besten werte gar nichts getan
gemeinsames beten an den feiertagen
beyond uhr dürfen immer nur sehr wenige
gemeinsam und mit abstand
viele israelis sehen sich zu unrecht mit
diesem lockdown gestraft und geben den
ultraorthodoxen und arabisch
israelischen gemeinden die schuld denn
dort gab es die höchsten
infektionszahlen weil die regierung dort
nicht früher und härter durchgegriffen
hat so ihre kritik muss nun das ganze
land die konsequenzen tragen
die folgen der korona krise werden auch
hierzulande noch lange zu spüren sein
und so plant finanzminister scholz auch
im kommenden jahr die im grundgesetz
verankerte schuldenbremse auszusetzen
für 2021 rechnet das ministerium mit
rund 96 milliarden euro neue schulden
zum vergleich in diesem jahr billigte
der bundestag eine neuverschuldung von
knapp 218 milliarden euro das war so
hoch wie nie rund um das thema krone und
gesundheit gab es heute im bundesrat und
bundestag jede menge beschlüsse an
seinem stern hat die wichtigsten für sie
zusammengefasst
mit einer geldspritze will der bundestag
die deutschen krankenhäuser stärker
drei milliarden euro werden
bereitgestellt die kliniken sollen
besser werden bei der versorgung von
notfallpatienten bei der digitalisierung
und bei der sicherheit ihrer it systeme
dabei geht es etwa um den schutz vor
hacker-angriffen extra geld soll es auch
geben für die die besonders kämpfen in
der krise einen bonus können kliniken
mit vielen virus patienten ihren
pflegekräften oder labor mitarbeitern
zahlen bis zu 1000 euro pro person
gesundheits beschlüsse heute auch im
bundesrat künftig soll es eine
elektronische patientenakte geben
ab dem ersten januar 2021 müssen die
krankenkassen ihren kunden eine solche
akte anbieten
darin können etwa röntgenbilder und
arztberichte gespeichert werden die
nutzung ist für die patienten freiwillig
neue verbote gibt es dagegen in der
tabakwerbung ab 2022 darf es keine
plakate mehr für tabakprodukte geben ab
2024 gilt das auch bei e zigaretten so
soll vor allem verhindert werden dass
junge menschen mit dem rauchen anfangen
und auch das beschloss der bundesrat der
sogenannte gaffer fotos von unfalltoten
aufnimmt dem drohen künftig bis zu zwei
jahre haft oder eine geldstrafe
auf eines konnte sich der bundesrat
nicht einigen
den überarbeiteten bußgeldkatalog als
der letzte im april in kraft trat
hagelte es kritik an den drastischen
strafen für zu schnelles fahren dann
musste das gesetz wegen eines
formfehlers außer kraft gesetzt werden
jetzt wollten einige die neufassung
nutzen um die strafe abzumildern
doch da spielten die grünen nicht mit
nicole diekmann überhöhte
geschwindigkeit bei der suche nach einem
kompromiss im streit um die
straßenverkehrsordnung kann davon keine
rede sein
wieder keine einigung im bundesrat dafür
enttäuschung bei der vorsitzende der
verkehrsministerkonferenz
deshalb bleibe ich auch dabei wäre es
gut gewesen nicht in eine nächste runde
zu gehen sondern die zeit zu nutzen die
wir auch durchaus hatten auch hin auf
diesen termin heute hier im bundesrat um
für eine gemeinsame linie zu sorgen
schon im februar hatte der bundesrat
eine reform abgelegt in der april trat
sie in kraft fahrverbote bereits bei
geschwindigkeitsüberschreitungen von 21
stundenkilometern innerorts 26
stundenkilometern außerorts autofahrer
gingen dagegen vor
auch per online-petition dann entdeckte
man an den formfehler das
verkehrsministerium setzte die reform
daraufhin außer kraft und wollte sie nun
auch im hinblick auf die fahrverbote
entschärfen
union und spd plädierten für einen
kompromiss fahrverbote für tempoverstöße
nur in besonders sensiblen bereichen
rund um kitas oder schulen etwa und im
wiederholungsfall die grünen aber
stellen sich quer
wir haben hier vor ein paar monaten
einstimmig ein bußgeldkatalog
beschlossen und den hätte ich eigentlich
gerne wenn das bundesverkehrsministerium
nicht den recht fehler gemacht hätte
dann hätten wir ja eine gültige
verordnung der bundesverkehrsminister
äußerte sich heute nach der entscheidung
schriftlich
schade sehr schade ein guter kompromiss
lag heute auf dem tisch besonders zum
schutz der schwächeren
verkehrsteilnehmer die grünen haben sich
heute für das scheitern und gegen den
kompromiss entschieden unsere hand
bleibt aber ausgestreckt die fronten
bleiben verhärtet der streit geht in die
nächste runde
wie umgehen mit russland soll die fast
fertige gaspipeline nord stream 2
gestoppt werden um druck auf moskau
auszuüben
darüber wird seit dem giftanschlag auf
den kreml-kritiker navalny heftig
gestritten heute auch im bundestag die
ministerpräsidenten der osten des länder
sind sich einig die pipeline sichere die
energieversorgung der zukunft und müsse
weiter müsse weiter gebaut werden lassen
sagt berichtet noch immer liegt alexej
nawalny in der berliner charité sein
zustand ist stabil der giftanschlag geht
nach ansicht der bundesregierung klar
auf moskaus konto als reaktion fordern
die grünen
nord stream zwei sofort zu stoppen sie
bedauern die dramatischen entwicklungen
in bilder aus dem krieg in der ukraine
die bombardierungen in syrien von
krankenhäusern und schulen gift
anschläge auf russische oppositionelle
aber zeitgleich konterkarieren sie mit
ihrer politischen unterstützung dieser
pipeline jegliche sanktionen mit ihrem
antrag stehen die grünen im bundestag
allerdings weitgehend alleine da die
linken werfen ihn gar doppelmoral vor
russland ist vielfach in einem
miserablen zustand gar keine frage aber
iran türkei saudi arabien fordern sie da
auch den abbruch wirtschaftlicher
beziehungen haben sie nach dem mord an
herrn georgi gefordert dass die
öllieferung die in einem antrag im
deutschen bundestag nichts dergleichen
geschlossen zeigen sich die ost
ministerpräsidenten sie fordert das
großprojekt zu ende zu bringen
auch aus gründen der energiesicherheit
über ein großes infrastrukturprojekt das
eben nicht allein ein russisches projekt
ist sondern ein infrastrukturprojekt im
interesse von deutschland von westeuropa
milliardenschwer 97 prozent sind bereits
fertiggestellt mehrfach durch ein
rechtsstaatliches genehmigungsverfahren
gegangen
im bundestag finden die grünen heute
keinerlei unterstützung entschieden wird
aber sowieso von der regierung auch dort
wird nord stream zwei kontrovers
diskutiert ziemlich reibungslos sind die
tarifgespräche bei der bahn verlaufen
der vertrag mit der gewerkschaft evg
steht angesichts der korona krise und
rekordschulden sei dass ein abschluss
mit augenmaß findet die bahn
entsprechend steigen die löhne nur mäßig
an zum ersten januar 2022 um 1,5 prozent
betriebsbedingte kündigungen wird es bis
februar 2023 nicht geben
außerdem verpflichtet sich die bahn in
den kommenden zwei jahren jeweils acht
10.000 neue mitarbeiter einzustellen
und jetzt corona und karneval
knapp zwei monate sind es noch bis zum
11 11 doch spätestens seit heute steht
für northeim
ahlen fest solche bilder wie im
vergangenen jahr sind undenkbar
was muss abgesagt werden was könnte noch
klappen bis gerade eben haben
karnevalisten und landesregierung in
düsseldorf darüber beraten und zwar über
szenarien vom kontrollierten frozen bis
hin zur total absage
dort fördert ist in düsseldorf dort wie
sie groß sind die chancen dass da
überhaupt was karneval mäßiges
stattfinden darf er es bleibt jedenfalls
nicht viel der straßenkarneval ist nach
der pandemie verordnung ohnehin verboten
nun ist auch der sitzungskarneval und
bälle die sind ebenfalls abgesagt die
landesregierung empfiehlt den städten
alkohol und verweilt verbote
auszusprechen und im gegenzug erhalten
die karnevalsvereine 50 millionen euro
unterstützung der chef der staatskanzlei
den karnevalisten zugerufen fahrt am
11.11 nicht in die hochburgen bleibt zu
hause und das einzige was noch möglich
ist sind sogenannte karnevalistische
kulturveranstaltungen
allerdings heißt es auch da das sei
nicht der karneval wie wir ihn kennen
das müsste jedem klar sein
also man muss sagen eigentlich es in
diesem jahr am 11 11
schon alles vorbei vielen dank für diese
informationen aus düsseldorf dort ferber
war das in die usa da hat der präsident
im poker um die chinesische video app
tech talk den druck noch einmal erhöht
bereits ab übermorgen kann die app in
den usa nicht nur heruntergeladen werden
wer sie bereits hat darf sie allerdings
vorerst weiter nutzen
donald trump verdächtigt tik tok der
spionage und drängt den chinesischen
mutterkonzern sein amerika geschäft zu
verkaufen
der chinesische kommunikationsdienste
week at ist ab sonntag sogar komplett
gesperrt es wirkte als ob das ende der
erde kurz bevorsteht so beschreibt eine
anwohnerin die waldbrände in den usa
seit mitte august bedrohen die flammen
den westen des landes
aktuell wütend großbrände von der grenze
zu kanada bis nach mexiko auch in los
angeles in kalifornien erleben die
menschen die folgen der waldbrände
hautnah
wolken aus asche die luft vielerorts
toxisch die feuerwehr kämpft einen fast
aussichtslosen kampf britta jäger
berichtet auf der einen straßenseite
stehen die häuser noch auf der anderen
haben die flammen schon zugeschlagen
3000 feuerwehrleute kämpfen in madeira
county kalifornien gegen das feuer
etwas weiter südlich kommt die
feuerfront los angeles gefährlich nahe
in den randbezirken der
millionenmetropole fliehen die anwohner
vor dem sogenannten bobcat feuer
landwirtin regen martin hilft einer
nachbarin möglichst viele tiere in
sicherheit zu bringen
wir sind alle ängstlich und wir wollen
dass möglichst alle hier leben preis
kommen wir arbeiten zusammen und
versuchen alles um auch die pferde und
andere tiere zu retten
5 mega brände wüten in kalifornien die
schlimmer sind als alles was der
bundesstaat in seiner geschichte hier
erlebt hat und auch im nachbarstaat
oregon wütend die feuer weiter
hier versuchen freiwillige schneisen in
die wälder zu schlagen um die flammen zu
stoppen und die häuser zu retten
alle kommen hier zusammen opfern ihre
zeit bringen essen equipment benzin
alles was man so braucht aber auch mit
all dem ist es fast unmöglich das feuer
aufzuhalten
längst ist an der us-westküste auch eine
debatte über die ursachen für die
feuerkatastrophe entbrannt ich denke
kein zweifel das ist der klimawandel
das sind waldbrände die passieren das
ist die natur
das muss nicht gut sein aber eben auch
nicht schlecht wissenschaftler sehen es
als erwiesen an dass der klimawandel
extreme trockenheit und hitze verschärft
außerdem seien in den vergangenen jahren
immer mehr menschen in feuer gefährdete
gebiete gezogen dort frisst sich das
feuer nun immer weiter durch und ist
kaum zu stoppen
ja jetzt zum sport rudi du bist ja der
dänische radprofi sören kah kanders und
gewinnt das drittletzte teilstück der
tour de france für den 26 jährigen vom
deutschen teams an rap ist es der zweite
etappensieg der diesjährigen tour im
gelben trikot
weiterhin der slowene primoz publik
nicht wie erwartet im massensprint
sondern durch diese aktion aus einer
zwölf mann starken spitzengruppe heraus
wird die neunzehnte etappe entschieden
sören anders und setzt sich 16 kilometer
vor dem ziel ab baut den vorsprung
schnell aus weil sie sich dahinter nicht
einig sind der däne gewinnt
eindrucksvoll seine zweite etappe bei
dieser tour de france der in der
gesamtwertung führende slowene primoz
rock ridge kommt im hauptfeld ins ziel
er muss seine 57 sekunden vorsprung auf
seinen landsmann ta dp jha jetzt noch
einmal verteidigen morgen beim
einzelzeitfahren 26 tage nach dem
champions league gewinnen eröffnet
bayern münchen heute abend ohne
zuschauer mit dem heimspiel gegen
schalke 04 die neue bundesliga saison
boris büchler nach dem grandiosen triple
erfolg scheint in münchen ja wohl nur
noch die sonne
na wo die so ganz sorgenfrei sind sie
eher nicht in münchen da gibt es den
trouble zwischen bayern und aller war
wegen des vertragspokers aller war zudem
leicht angeschlagen muskulär haben wir
eben erfahren ja insgesamt ein
ungleiches duell denn die schalker haben
sondern januar kein bundesliga spiel
mehr gewonnen
alles spricht also für die bayern und
alle sprechen über legasthenie vor fünf
minuten hier in die marina arena
einmarschiert er wird heute sein
pflichtspieldebüt bei bayern feiern dies
allerdings vor leeren rängen corinna
bedingt tor ist vielen dank für die
infos aus münchen bayern schalke 20.15
dann hier bei uns im zdf der deutsche
handball-meister thw kiel zeigt beim
neustart der champions league eine
starke vorstellung
die mannschaft siegt beim kroatischen
serienmeister rk zagreb mit 31 zu 21 vor
allem neuzugang sandra sarkozy imponiert
beim überzeugenden kantersieg der
norweger erzielt sieben treffer und wird
als bester spieler ausgezeichnet und der
schwedische stabhochspringer armee
geplant ist feiert einen erfolg für die
sport geschichtsbücher beim diamond
league meeting der leichtathleten in rom
knackt der 20-jährige die freiluft
bestmarke des legendären ukrainers
sergej bubka aus dem jahr 1994 im
zweiten versuch
überquert der sechs meter 15 1 und
zentimeter höher als bub kv 26 jahren
das war der sport zu bauer 615 nicht
schlecht kriegen wir nicht hin freuen
können sie sich aufs wetter am
wochenende das wird nämlich sonnig und
warm gewitter gibt es höchstens in den
alpen die details hat gleich gunther
tiersch immer halbzeitpause gegen
viertel nach neun begrüßt 7 marietta
slomka im heute journal
wir danken für ihr interesse das gesamte
19 uhr team wünscht ihnen ein schönes
wochenende und bis morgen wenn sie mit
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend liebe zuschauer das
wochenende bei uns wird sonnig und auch
ziemlich warm diese spätsommerliche
wärme hat sich weit ausgebreitet in
europa reicht von london über warschau
bis zur ukraine
heiß ist es über frankreich mit 30 grad
und regen fällt am mittelmeer vor allen
dingen griechenland jetzt bei 20 bis 25
grad
bei uns wird frisch in der nacht
temperaturen also drei bis sieben grad
das bedeutet örtlich bodenfrost wieder
im westen ist es deutlich milder mit
zehn bis zwölf grad und ist es eine
sternenklare nacht mit flachen
nebelfeldern die sich tagsüber dann
schnell weg heizen also es wird ein
überwiegend sonniger tag dichtere wolken
ziehen höchstens mal über die küsten
hinweg und auch im südwesten wird es am
späten nachmittag so ein bisschen
bewölkter werden aber es bleibt trocken
und werden weiterhin diesen frischem
ostwind allerdings nicht mehr so stark
wie heute
die temperaturen steigen auch im norden
etwas an meist sind es 18 bis 22 grad
genauso wie südlich der donau und hier
im westen und südwesten sind es wieder
23 bis 28 grad die nächsten tage
versprechen wieder viel sonnenschein bei
uns temperaturen ähnlich eben zwischen
20 27 grad örtlich gibt es auch gewitter
vor allen dingen am dienstag wohl auch
im westen
ich wünsche ihnen einen schönen abend
und machen sie's gut